if we were to survey a hundred different
people say 40 Republicans 40 Democrats
20 independent Libertarians and say
how well of a job you think Biden's
going to do given the State of the Union
speech okay and they put their scores
before before not after before I think
the average person is going to say you
know four a five and what it's what
they're going to expect for him to do
right it's like a guy you have that's on
the bench who averages six points a game
and you put him in he scored 17 points
you're like dude we were not expecting
17 points from this guy I think that's
what he did he went in and I think it
was a very good look for him the
Democrats again my opinion on what
happened the most awkward part was that
okay I think the part that I give credit
to is the following I'll get into that
here in a minute here's some of the
things he talked about number one
inflation he blamed Putin on inflation
we caught that so that Blame Game you
don't gain credibility there anytime you
do that but we know where that's going
and then the last two years 10 million
jobs 10 million Americans have applied
to start a new business okay so you're
kind of appealing to the small business
owner we get that that's a good speech
that's given then the next thing was
social security every five years you
know how Rick Scott is negotiating for
this I think that was a massive massive
victory for him it because it was off
the cuff it was uncomfortable if you can
play it this is like if you show a
highlight of Michael Jordan going over
Sam Perkins and switching and making the
the shot with his left hand I think this
was his moment if you want to just press
play so the audience can zoom just zoom
in so they can hear it and see it yeah
zoom in even closer
even closer you don't need to see the
words just to face there you go if you
can click on it so watch this just a
moment audio on the bottom right
there wasn't all the oil refineries
anyway so this isn't the one this is
this is a completely different thing
this is the oil refinery one the one I'm
talking about is where uh what is this
one here no that's a different one as
well there's a clip where the
Republicans and him they're talking
about social security oh yeah and
they're talking about Medicare so if you
go on YouTube or Twitter and type on
Social Security Medicare Biden it'll
come up I think that was his highlight
and you know I know it's very hard for
Republicans to even give credit to them
I think that's his highlight is that the
one how many minutes is that buck 37
that should be the one press play and
audio
pay their fair share something okay
rewind some Republicans watch this
here's when it gets nasty I get it
unless I agree to their economic plans
all of you at home should know what
those plans are watch this
instead of making the wealthy pay their
fair share so I'm very happy
some Republicans want Medicare and
Social Security Sunset
I'm not saying it's a majority yeah what
one person talked to you about it great
setup yeah anybody who doubts it contact
my office
wait wait watch for it wait for it
proposal
that means Congress doesn't vote
I enjoy conversion
you know
Congress doesn't keep the programs the
way they are that's what other
Republicans say I'm not saying it's a
majority of you I don't even think it's
even a significant
but it's being proposed by individuals
I'm not politely not naming them but
it's being proposed by some of you
look folks
the idea is that we're not going to be
we're not going to be moved into being
threatened to default on the debt if we
don't watch this
folks watch he Corners them
and then he makes all the Republicans
stand up watch this
this is his highlights
so folks as we all apparently agree
Social Security Medicare is off the off
the books now
all right
watch this and then no hang on you don't
have any more oh the best part is
missing you know what's the best part
what he does right after this he says so
can we all stand up if you agree to
protect seniors and he makes every body
stand body stand up that even booed him
so look if you if you can go minute 40
to go all the way to the last 10 seconds
yeah that's the one
don't do that don't do that because it's
hurting the ears
all right
we got unanimity
go back to Buck 20. yeah go back here
so folks as we all apparently agree
he gets everybody else to stand up so I
thought that was a defining moment for
him that's a highlight okay for him to
and this is why let me explain why okay
you have to know this is we don't sit
here every week and talk about how
amazing Joe Biden is okay but to me
strategically when you
go off the script and it's all about the
teleprompter and there is a 75 second
moment that you can't lean on the
teleprompter and that comes off the cuff
to do that I think you got to give the
guy credit on being able to leverage on
any kind of corn in McCartney because he
took away a couple cards away to
negotiate now I would love to see your
thoughts because you look like you got a
couple things I disagree with just about
all of that first of all McCarthy
announced the morning before the speech
yeah that that Medicaid and Associated
off the table I'm not going to consider
Cuts in any ways Joe just lost his big
Bugaboo issue they always use in October
a vote against the Republicans they're
going to cut your Social Security it's
very clear that that's not in our plan
I've also never seen that kind of
reaction at all in a in a uh in the
State of the Union Address they take one
Senator Rick Scott who has a plan by the
way I don't think any other Senator
supports uh and uh he signals him out
and tries to imply that that this is a a
a
this is a more emblematic of the overall
Republican party so I don't think I I
think he just lost an issue that they
use as a scare tactic because no one
understands and Trump by the way tweeted
about this prior to the event that to
the Republicans saying Social Security
Medicare have to be off the table uh the
other thing here of course is that our
politics moves so fast and our
electorate is so volatile that any
conclusion we reach here today or any
impression that Biden makes uh on the
voters
can change within days I mean as we've
seen in this recent controversy
regarding the Chinese surveillance
balloon an event like that can so
completely suck up suck up the oxygen on
all political coverage and change things
overnight
no I absolutely kind of uh agree that he
did I was surprised by Biden to be quite
honest I mean every time he goes up to
speak you just wonder what he's going to
do to screw it up or how he's going to
make it look worse but in this beach
overall I was I was thoroughly impressed
he looked presidential and especially
considering the way he was at his
campaigns speeches and how he's was
stumbling and going back and forth and
you're like what what's going on it was
like watching a NASCAR race and
everybody watches it to watch I want to
see the big crash and you just saw some
fender benders but nothing really really
bad happened because mind you when I
watch speeches like that module I'm
embarrassed as as an American citizen as
a veteran because I'm I'm biting my
nails like what because he messed up a
couple times some words you know he's he
can't really articulate them I think he
said prescription drugs once but he was
like
he's like like a like a four-year-old
but I mean it's just like you're waiting
for like mistake and like who knows bro
he's he's right on the edge of like even
the way he walks I mean I feel I
genuinely feel bad bad for him because I
think he's he's at that point I don't I
don't I don't think he should run but I
by the way the running conversation is a
different conversation yeah that's a
whole different conversation we can have
afterwards but to me you know right
afterwards Sarah Huckabee Sanders gave a
speech and she said you know I'm
officially the youngest governor in
America at 40 years old and President
Biden is the oldest president ever at 80
years old to give the message that she
he gave so I think America is kind of
tired with you know the messaging all
I'm saying is in this specific moment I
want to find that scene because I think
it is a scene that we have to see I
think I found it here where he gets
everyone to have to stand up it's at an
out yeah there it is it's right here
I'll send the link to you to go to hour
in one minute uh to share with them but
I'll keep going with the other topics
that I have
um he had the parents of Tyree Nichols
there which is a good way to connect
with what took place and uh a very great
opportunity for uh connection to talk
about law enforcement needs training
great fine so he hit that if Congress
suggests a national ban I will veto it
great fine story of fentanyl which that
was a very bad look for him because you
don't talk about what you're fixing when
your leader who needs to go to the
Border Kamala doesn't even go to talk to
the people at the border it's a hundred
percent hypocrisy whether you're middle
Center left right it doesn't matter you
can't talk in that topic with a lot of
um
credibility I thought the baby that
fought cancer I thought I was a good
story great story that he gave heartfelt
again he hit the heartfelt messages uh
that took place Paul Pelosi standing up
I don't know who said to have even a
shout out to Paul Pelosi I don't think
that was a good look because things are
too fresh and uh you know you don't want
a guy that's hanging out with another
guy with a hammer and a beer in his hand
in their underwear to kind of give an
endorsement to a person like that's a
little awkward that's always another six
or twelve months before it was it was
weird but to make that I think that was
like like feel bad for don't get me
wrong I felt bad the guy was attacked
but all this stuff leading up to him and
the police video all the questions of
what they said it was so what you saw
was like wait a minute they looked like
they were just somebody walked in on
them you know what I mean so but the but
the the one where he tripped on his own
deal is the one that I just gave you if
you can go to that the one that you had
up originally which was the oil issue
okay which was the oil issue which I
think is this one yeah one yeah
for a decade
and that's going to exceed the play the
player I'll be honest look at this watch
this this is what the with the oil yeah
you need the audio you don't need oil
for that oh yeah this was it you're
gonna shut down all the oil wells and
all the uh oil refiners anyways
I said we're going to need oil for at
least another decade
let me come out of space You shouldn't
have said that we're gonna need it you
see him when I talked to say we're
afraid you're going to shut down what
did you think about this one so much for
the new green deal huh
absolutely I mean look it's a reality he
had you had for the first time you had
energy Independence under Trump every
president Republican and Democrat they
always pledged it nobody ever did it uh
there's enough natural oil and natural
gas under the under U.S territory to
fuel the country for the next hundred
years uh for the first time we don't
have to go hat in hand to the Middle
East or to Venezuela for oil
we turn on the Russian Pipeline that
Trump shut down we shut down our
pipeline this makes this makes no sense
at all and now Joe Biden has just
essentially uh contradicted the dogma of
his party that we need to be moving off
fossil fuels immediately I thought it
was one of the weakest parts of the
speech and of course Republicans were
high-fiving each other yeah by the way
that was uh again you
so here's kind of how I see this
there are a few people who can do
without the teleprompter he's not one of
them definitely at all okay if you were
to even count on your hand how many
people can give a talk for an hour or
two or three without a teleprompter it's
not a long list of names okay who would
you say you you you followed this sport
closer than anybody else Trump is one of
them who else can go without a
teleprompter very few we make an
excellent point very few would you put
Obama on Dallas and Clinton on that list
uh I think Obama could probably do it I
think so I think he's taste talented
Clinton Clinton could definitely do it
the problem is Clinton would talk for
two hours yeah
they're like like giving the light to
get off he was good though when he was
tired at least he wouldn't entertain him
when he would do his part all I'm saying
is to follow him here's kind of how this
works it's like you know you're in your
floaties in the middle of the ocean
you're okay you're doing fine okay you
let the floaties go oh [__] it's risky
yeah I bet a lot of the people who are
the speech writers they kept saying
president of mine suggestion just stick
to the teleprompter you can pause take
your time but just read it slowly we're
gonna be okay the moment he was out
there without the floaties yeah oh my
God what are we gonna go I won't he made
one of them up which is the Medicare and
Social Security because he got that
older vote the baby boomer vote the way
he did it well maybe he got them to
listen but then he slipped out with the
oil one yeah and the old one where the
Democrats are like bro you just stick to
the flip and script teleprompter what
are you doing so that's the part with
him so I he had his flip flop he had a
few turnovers but I also thought he made
a few good plays no absolutely I think
especially with uh on the on the on the
Democrat side of how they've been so
against the oil the green New Deal and
pushing that forward the reality is
there's no doubt that there's going to
be some sort of transition to some point
down the road but obviously they're
pushing for a very heavy now everything
abolish oil get rid of it this that and
the other and what he just proved was
that the reality is that's not the case
but that's what they're pushing for so
he just kind of screwed up their
argument on that end the other obvious
uh balloon in the room not the Chinese
one is it he has a little section there
where he talks about being tough on
China and saying well we we just were
tough on them but but in fact we let
this balloon into U.S airspace we let it
essentially navigate all the way across
the country from Montana to the
Carolinas
and then only then and only then do we
do anything about it other than sending
a strong letter to the Chinese I think
he sustained more damage from that over
the last week than anything he picked up
with tough on China rhetoric in this
speech the Chinese were paying us
billions and billions and billions of
dollars in tariffs he canceled that
program uh the Chinese clearly watching
are fumbling in Afghanistan uh watching
what's going on in in Ukraine they've
definitely got plans regarding Taiwan
and the lesson of history is that
weakness provokes aggression weakness
provokes War
yeah with the Spin Doctors showed up
very quickly and they set a balloon
under Trump was there for a while and
you know nothing was done about it and
these balloons are normal balloons and
then the the average voters sitting
there saying oh but maybe this is just a
normal thing with all these balloons
that they have I I don't think I don't
think that so the Secretary of Defense
says nobody told me that there were
Chinese balloons in U.S airspace nobody
else in the National Security apparatus
so I think it's an effort to try to make
it usual no big deal yeah I I don't
think I don't think it works so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]